on pourrait croire qu'il a dit fougère
était prédestiné à un retour à la terre
on s'est donné
une bonne le travail est physique
exigeant le salaire lui 14 dollars 25h
pour le salaire que j'ai commencé
l'expérience c'était vraiment plus pour
apprendre puis vivre l'expérience de
travail sur une ferme c'est aussi là
qu'elle habite en échange d'un loyer
modique elle évite ainsi les frais de
déplacement d'autant plus que ces
sorties se font rares salaires minimum
oblige
dans le petit chat puis je médite puis
je fais mon yoga j'aimerais studio
sans avoir l'appartement ici à la ferme
sans habiter proche puis avoir des
légumes je sais pas comment que je
réussis à m'en sortir avec le salaire
que je fais je sais pas le nombre de
personnes qui travaillent encore ça un
minimum aujourd'hui mais 300000 au
Québec présentement environ 300 000
personnes
[Musique]
sans travailleurs plus précisément selon
les dernières estimations du ministère
de l'Emploi c'est 8% des salariés de la
province la plupart ont entre 15 et 24
ans plus de la moitié sont des femmes et
dans 70% des cas les emplois occupés
sont dans les secteurs du commerce au
détail de l'hébergement et de la
restauration
les travailleurs de SOS vélo un
organisme d'insertion ont longtemps fait
partie de ces statistiques
l'organisme pige dans son budget déjà
serré pour offrir un taux horaire d'un
dollar de plus que le salaire minimum
chaque souhaitée
pour Stéphane Tremblay les forts est
apprécié mais restez insuffisant pour
affronter l'inflation surtout pendant la
recherche d'un nouveau logement
j'arriverai pas à payer sur l'eau
c'est justement pour alléger ce stress
financier que plusieurs organismes
demandent une augmentation immédiate du
salaire minimum pour le faire passer à
au moins 18 dollars l'heure 18 $ c'est
vraiment le minimum que ça prend pour
être en mesure de penser sortir de la
pauvreté c'est-à-dire d'être capable de
payer le loyer de mettre la nourriture
sur la table de pouvoir s'habiller se
déplacer ça ferait que ça serait des
personnes que tu pourrais payer leur
épicerie tu pourrais vivre au lieu de
survivre j'ai beaucoup de doutes sur la
pertinence de demande mais pour cette
économie une augmentation aussi
importante serait néfaste pour bien des
entreprises elle aussi confrontée à
l'inflation les entrepreneurs ne sont
pas opposés conceptuellement augmenter
les salaires mais ne peuvent pas le
faire tout en restant rentable et
évidemment si notre entreprise ferme
tout le monde qui travaille là perte de
l'emploi ils sont pas mieux avancés
selon lui la solution devrait plutôt
passer par des mesures plus ciblées pour
aider les parents à faible revenu
notamment ça serait génial Stéphane et
sans grande surprise de ceux qui prônent
une augmentation majeure et rapide du
salaire minimum mais en attendant ces
objectifs restent modestes devant la
hausse du bout de la vie peu importe de
savoir que tu gagnes la pomme à
[Musique]